da ein kleiner zombie hatte gerade ein
eisen schwert in der irgendwann nach
unten
burkhalter ich bin halt ein foto
geschossen dich sterben ach du scheiße
sind wir wieder über die man aber hier
waren gar nicht out doch hier sind ja
noch so viel durchlässiger 4 5 6 7 8 9
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu captain
minecraft 2 zusammen mit komme hd und
wir haben in der letzten folge ein
weiteres moment erlangt und zwar haben
wir bereits gefunden und dann diese
semmering hin was ich mal ganz kurz
zeige
okay es ist jetzt zu google song
geworden aber wir haben es geschafft wie
er dasteht und hier kommen dann ein
neuer dorfbewohner kamen an
und was passt halt noch zu sagen dass
man halo von gome wahrscheinlich ja
danke danke danke danke con crafter dass
du net wie immer ich habe meine spitze
hier einmal komplett runter geworfen
die ganzen leiter weg runter wohlstand
nach unten geht
sehr geil okay was wir heute machen aber
ich mache ich mehr parat erst mal die
kür
wir haben dann noch zwei stück besieger
ein gast mit seinen eigenen waffen
eigentlich wollten wir auch nochmal den
server restart aber gut dann nicht
sonst könnte man ja man die hölle gehen
und gucken ob da ein gast ist okay
verdammt stimmt wir wollen den service
daten krank machen wir es kurz machen
was ich mache ganz unten in das ende
er finde das alles auch noch so ein ding
wir müssen und wir könnten auch einfach
das ende finden
aber nicht aussuchen nicht verlassen wir
sagen wir in die hülle und wingas finden
ich wäre dafür dass wenn man am ende
suchen dann können wir mal unten in die
höhe dann bereiten wir uns ein bisschen
drauf vorne machen wir gleich wenn wir
den cup zur nächsten folge dann
machen wir dann wieder die hölle und
suchen netter warzen okay gut dann
müssen uns eben auf die hölle auf die
höhe aber nicht auf die hölle sondern
auf die höhle und vorbereiten
du könntest wenn du willst mal neue
suppen holen weil wir hier nicht mehr so
viele haben und die sind acht lehrer
schüsseln gute idee was ich mal direkt
ich nehme noch ein paar koppel stones
mit zum hoch bauen
ich brauche noch eine spitzhacke haben
wir noch irgendwo reisen dann weißt du
das weißt du was eingelegt ich hab nur
ein eisen warte ich prinz m hoch ich
möchte hier war ganz leisen eisenstück
das was dann machen wir eben noch eine
spitzhacke sony schal nach da sind die
schalen ja so viel habe ich ein paar
viel mehr braucht man eigentlich gar
nicht essen steine spitzhacke waffe
fackeln könnte ich mir noch ein paar
mehr machen aber sonst wie bisschen ab
filtering komische welt der wipfel kommt
da rein so ein paar fackeln sticks mit
falls wir unsere network management
falls wieder und irgendwie verhungern
oder ja falls die erfahrung und ich
nehme meine workbench mit ich glaube ich
nochmals eine halbe liga mit wir sind
jetzt richtig gut vorbereitet alter okay
so haben wir auch sehr gut ich habe
keine rüstung du hast eine rüstung ich
nicht ja ich habe ja ein bisschen okay
da sind suppen gut meint mit
ich hab schon schallplatte uli masuth
weil ich schon voll viele habe auch
schon voll viel
na gut weil wir eine suppe wir könnten
auch theoretisch auf unsere spitzhacke
glück eins machen und dann schon die
diamanten abbauen damit machen
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ob mein
glück zwei auch noch einfach bekommen
will und ob wir uns dann später er ganz
nach dem motto auf warum haben wir kein
glück zweier aufgemacht soll ich mal
einfach aus jux und tollerei einmal
verzaubern werden in diesem tisch meinem
einen unbenutzten spitzhacke dafür
braucht man eigentlich nicht doch man
muss da plötzlich neben legen damit man
verzaubern kann ja das ist neu ich kann
nur bis level 8 gehen soll wir machen
haltbarkeit als 11 dann steht das sei ja
auch neben was man bekommt ja ach ist
das haltbarkeit und effizienz verdammen
versorger nehme
wir brauchen glück nicht verkehrt glück
auf nadia spitzenposten achsen hand
nicht dass du noch da irgendwie gleich
eine axt reinlegt sehe ich hab dann ich
hab eine spezielle reingelegt wirklich
einen dia spitzhacke können wir nicht
einfach eisen spezialkoffer zaubern der
warum nicht die hier mal wieder ein
riesenspektakel mitnehmen müssen ja city
verlieren weil ich ja gut dann
verzaubert wie die dia spitzhacke
haltbarkeit die haltbarkeit braucht
wenig wir brauchen glück im norden
wir müssten noch so ein ding daneben
legen
bücherregal ich nehme erst mal alles
raus von bücher verbinden kann so papier
ich brauch ledersattel gab es doch nicht
in erfolg irgendwie schweinereien
dafür brauchen wir eine fliege auf einem
schwein
achja haben wir keine speisen ich glaube
ich muss gleich mal einfach irgendwann
schweinchen kommen so moment i hat es
kann nicht sein dass keiner von uns
leder hat oder so kann sein hellster
kühl getötet jaja daraus habe ich dann
auch zwei bücherregale gemacht aber halt
nur zwei stück so ich habe wieder zwei
leder das heißt ich habe wieder zwei
bücher machen ob der plan ist also mein
plan ist jetzt folgender ich gebe in die
höhle und schau mal wie viele diamanten
nicht an um im auge erkennen kann
erzähle ich nach wir brauchen ja für ein
blog 92 18 43 27 okay wahrscheinlich hat
wieder zwei bücher aber das reichte
nicht mehr für ein regal
wir haben jetzt vier bücher also ich hab
mich in der kiste das reicht für neues
bücher
das heißt ich nehme jetzt jeder raus bla
bla mache jetzt ein neues bücherregal
so habe ein neues bücherregal
ich setze das jetzt eben daneben hier
jetzt können wir nämlich schon da hast
du dir zeit mitgenommen oder die liegt
noch immer in der wertvollen truhe im
moment ja oder sm diamant spitzhacke so
und lapislazuli okay ja ich kann jetzt
können wir bis level 11 aber immer noch
nicht besser als haltbarkeit und
effizienz wir brauchen noch viel mehr
bücher hinaus vielleicht noch ein paar
malereien vielleicht kommt er ja gleich
glück habe ich schon mehrmals gemacht
bei glück ist echt selten nur
haltbarkeit und effizienz besser nicht
das ist ein was ist agenda will ist auch
dazu liegt
wenn ich das ja wohl absatz wie daran
hapert es nicht ich hab mal schwert rein
ich kann die schärfe 1 bahnen und
haltbarkeit
wenn ich schade
gut da werden wir wahrscheinlich noch
mehr irgendwie zuckerrohr versuchten
familien hier wo kompletten er ja aus
der höhle die genau unter unserer basis
ist das sind 1000 monster 1000 echt ok
wat ich komme jetzt mal als christin ich
denke mal eben die sachen die wertvoll
sind wieder in die kirche ganz unten
werden diamanten höhle alles gefällt mir
hier aber ich komme gleich auch dahin wo
ich packe es noch eben schnell die
sachen weg so weit kommt noch hier ein
die gestern mit dass and portal das muss
irgendwo hier stecken aber ich habe
eigentlich alles ganz unten unter höhe
das muss ein global hub ist ein ganz
unten oder wo bleibt uns ganz unten
kommen noch ganz unten alter in der ich
bin gerade einmal an der höhle unter
unserem haus her da sind ja echt immens
viele monster dass ich krank
ok wenn bei dir warte ich bin ganz unten
also bist doch lange ich bei mir doch
ich sehe jetzt auf jeden fall schon das
ende von dem kann er musste aber noch
weiter runter da kommt da ja noch der
wasserturm das wegen seiner leiter
gemacht nach unten oder oder wie weil du
musst erst mal die schlucht rein
okay ich bin jetzt bin jetzt durch den
wasserfall nach unten
ja und noch weiter runter das dann er
bald eine schlucht
michael sommer wo ist eine schlucht
conny ich sehe keine schluss nicht
irgendeine kleine monster ein kleiner
zombie hatte gerade ein eisenstädter in
der immer nach unten
walter ich bin hat ihn vater geschossen
dich sterben achten scheiße sind hier
wieder über die mannschaft wieder
richtig frieren das niveau ist ich hab
dich doch zimmer gefallen wo du ja ganz
unten einfach den wasserfall runter
weiter den wasserfall runter ja okay
jetzt sich der name müssten fall weit
oben wo ich hier keine hochkommen kommt
nach unten
mai nahm den wasserfall runter ja ich
hab nicht zu dir gerade ich musste
erstmal generieren hier sehr so viel
gold bin jetzt schon hier bei dir gleich
so ich bin gerade unter der erde und gab
mich ganz so ein bisschen durch ich bin
jetzt neben dir kommen hoch hier
ok ich komme da ich mache ich komme da
zu die jetzt unter hier so dass wasser
ach du hast doch gesagt hab ich gesagt
das wasser ist ja gut das habe ich ja
ich bin ich bin hinter dir übrigens
gerade ne
ach ja das stimmt
diese schlucht hier stimmen stimmt
stimmt da wo diese heftige explosion war
von dir ja so darf ich wieder reden
sollte hier runter kohle warte ich nehme
noch kohlemeilern ein junger wir heizen
die ganze zeit mit holz das ist richtig
abartig wir heizen alles durch olé olé
olé okay ich sage mal auf monster jetzt
einfach hier passiert hier komplett lava
das immer aufgehen
und jetzt bist du dir unten angekommen
in der abwehr ablehne
ich hab gehört ist es gar nicht aber
monster
halt auf der anderen seite geht ja auch
noch weiter existiere glow ich genau und
tieren da hast du überall diamanten so
stimmt dann muss man ja auch in die
gänge reingehen wo ich man sagte ihr
gegangen wären nur mit irgendwas mit
glück abbauen ja eben oder wer
verzaubern bücher ich ich legt nochmal
die diamanten freimann 18 wieviel alter
hat man wenig luft gesprengt werden
wurde das mal frei hier habt ihr mann
noch mal gefunden zumal hier oben rechts
zu warnen
die wurden gerade frei geschüttet einer
theoretisch mal wieder den trick mit der
spitzhacke atmen hier sind auch wieder
welche ja das war die von neben die zum
fall schüttet gegangen so hier den
schritt mit der spitzhacke will einfach
wirklich mal alle frei gramm und mal
gucken wie viele werden haben dann
vielleicht braucht er gar kein glück
eben eben vielleicht reicht er schon
einmal glück 1 man braucht vielleicht
denn gleich glück 2 so also ob jung war
wir haben wir brauchen noch viel sagen
wir mal 27 diamanten würdig grob
schätzen weiß ja nie wie viel kommt hin
hier sind 233 22 soll ich hoffe jetzt
natürlich gänge so hier in der decke
haben wir noch mal eins es noch einige
hier sind 12 34 legt die komplett frei
ja ich glaube wir sind jetzt die wir
müssen das am besten gemeinsam ablaufen
okay sagt der eine hier war ich schon
andere zählt es dann nochmal mit das
treibt dann erst mal alle diamanten die
wir finden wie freilegen
ich mache mir die lava kurz hierzu dann
am ende können wir gemeinsam der
langlauf und björn hat er hier sind ja
so viele diamanten gefunden alter falter
wir sind ja so viele diamanten weil ich
so ein glück mal weil bei wago gehabt
das wären bei war oh ja ich hab ihr 30
diamanten gefunden
ich habe mich mal hier weiter lang alter
moment ich hier viele diamanten
fegert nur kohle
ich würde an seiner stelle schon mal
irgendwie glück auf die spitzhacke
machen und wieder kommen dann können wir
noch in einer folge hier alles abbauen
ja aber wie soll ich erst dann drauf
packen übernahm box einfach ein amboss
das buch auf der linken seite auf die
hagener bücher
die habe ich ja für bücherregale
auskommen doch eindruck meint ruhe
gefunden mit glück 1 bio in meiner
letzten folge der vorletzten folge
ich bin auf dem weg nach oben so aber
wir sind schon mal zwölf minuten das
heißt es bringt kann ich da machen wir
das lieber in einer folge das heißt ich
lauf gleich nach oben packte glück drauf
bringt die runter und haben hier schon
mal diamanten ab aber wir waren doch
hier sind ja noch so viel durchlässiger
4 5 6 7 8 9 12 13 14 15 16 17
im gang sei noch welche 18 19 20
mit glück 1 okay leute in der nächsten
folge wird es schaffen wir den block auf
diamond kacke
auf dem kanal morgen bis dann haut ein
schimmel lala